alright guys we're here with Caitlin
long super excited about this
conversation I think you so much for
coming nice to finally meet you
absolutely let's uh let's just go
through your background but I don't want
you to kind of gloss over anything I
want you to actually go through every
step of it so we can really get into
kind of the The Wall Street aspect and
then how you got into crypto but in
crypto since early probably 2013 I
discovered it in 2012 didn't actually
get my first bitcoins until 2013 how to
keep my head down so and the reason is
because I was on Wall Street at that
time I was running a business at Morgan
Stanley and spent 22 years in total on
Wall Street from 94 through 2016 have a
legal background although I've never
practiced law I've been a member the bar
since way back when and then prior to
that grew up in Wyoming which is going
to be relevant I think we're gonna talk
about the Wyoming blockchain bills yeah
so when you get to Wall Street what was
kind of your first job and they walked
me through the different you know parts
of the business on Wall Street I worked
in investment banking at Salomon
Brothers doing financial institutions so
just let you know landed there by luck
not a particular interest it's just
that's where I got assigned absolutely
and found financial institutions
incredibly interesting so did a lot of
of work in bank mergers and insurance
company mergers and ended up kind of
steering over towards insurance I find
that a fascinating industry and all of
the 22 years had something to do with
insurance that I worked on Wall Street
what why is that so interesting well
it's it's uh it's the law of large
numbers it's it's actually a really math
based industry so and and part of the
reason I didn't practice law is I
discovered I was better at math and
words to put it simply and so that the
math has always interested me and I
don't have a you know certainly a high
level math background like a
cartographer would but but I knew enough
to know and and ended up running a
couple of insurance companies within
Wall Street firms during those years
very very cool yeah okay and so walk me
through your on Wall Street you know at
that point you'd been there almost 20
years right and what's the first time
somebody tells you about Bitcoin or you
kind of stumble across it and what was
your reaction yeah
it was it was the libertarian community
it was free state group
I discovered Austrian economics out of
curiosity in during the 2008 financial
crisis I figured out that the mainstream
explanation of the financial crisis just
didn't make sense and it was a
contradiction that Tim Geithner made on
Charlie Rose's show where he talked
about how interest rates were too low
going into the crisis and he had just
been arguing that interest rates needed
to be lowered still and so obviously
that I thought I just thought it was a
logical and and Doug and at the time
stayed in touch with a lot of hedge fund
friends they were all trying to figure
out figure everything out they'd found
Austrian economics before the financial
crisis in a lot of cases but they dug in
and you know they even pointed me to the
garrison powerpoints that's that's an
obscure Austrian reference that a lot of
folks probably a lot of your listeners
will understand but if you haven't seen
those they are incredible absolutely and
so as you're kind of going into that
rabbit hole and you're discovering all
this stuff you hear about Bitcoin what
it's kind of that first reaction oh I
didn't believe it and it was also you
know in those days there was no UI and
and so it was not a technologist my
background and I was intimidated by it
and and just scratched my head and
couldn't believe it like a lot of people
and you start reading and I the reason I
remember it was February 2013 when I
first started to set up a while it is
Jeffrey Tucker sent an email around and
in fact a few months ago I actually
saved that email and I had sent it back
to Jeffrey a few months ago to remind
him of when's the first time he started
writing about Bitcoin it was in an email
from on LASIK their books and I happened
to be flat on my back after having had a
surgery and for a couple days so I had
time to really dig into it it takes time
and it takes a lot of repetition and
Jeffrey had some some how-to advice in
that email it was never published on a
website although when I sent it back to
him a couple of months ago he published
it just so he could kind of have a
record of absolutely yeah and so what
where'd you go to buy a Bitcoin right so
this is 2013 it's pretty early there's
not really that many places where you
know
when people are talking about this stuff
and to kind of what I would consider a
really great user experience or a user
interface so without the technology
background what do you do yeah that was
the there were eight there was an ATM up
at Liberty forum yes yeah and so yeah
that wasn't actually I'm very first
Bitcoin came from the blockchain dot
info guys they were up at little bitty
Liberty forum explaining and they they
hosted a how-to and it was very well
attended by a lot of curious people and
and set up another wallet through them
and and then they sent us for action you
know a few Satoshi's and then i went out
and put $20 into a Bitcoin ATM yeah that
is amazing story yeah alright so we go
from 2013 to over the next 2-3 years
kind of what is your relationship with
Bitcoin crypto I mean you go deeper and
deeper into the rabbit hole get more
excited about it still on Wall Street
still on Wall Street and and and and a
very good friend of mine ari levy Cohen
who's the one of the co-founders of
singular DTV he was also at Morgan
Stanley at the time and he was he had
gone down the rabbit hole and more so
than I and more technologically savvy
than I was and so you know was already
digging he was already running a full
node I think at that point and so he was
really helpful to me in in understanding
it and there was another the third of
the three Morgan Stanley Musketeers Jake
Dean alt who you probably cross paths
with unfortunately he passed away as you
know but the three of us came from very
different parts of Morgan Stanley and we
connected with each other over Bitcoin
I'd known Ari previously but we really
got to know each other more closely it's
like the secret society of crypto on
Wall Street well and there was an
internal Morgan Stanley Bitcoin email
list a forum that got going and what was
fun about it is when I saw when I joined
it they were already probably I don't
know 50 people on it and it grew to
hundreds of people this is like doesn't
it yeah 2014 and you know everybody
everybody was afraid right a bit of the
compliance Department no one knew what
the implications for being involved with
this would be and so in the beginning I
just lurked and I noticed that most of
the people were younger and ie more
junior
but but but they were off from all over
the place it wasn't that just the
technology department and it wasn't just
the United States it was literally all
over the world a very diverse
cross-section of people who are
interested in this and and it just
really blossomed and as I as it
blossomed I started to participate and
then I got a phone call from the chief
technology officer because I was a
managing director running a business and
so you know I had a little gray hair so
to speak and he said come on into my
office and tell me what this is and you
know the board had it turned out just
asked him at the time I think this was
2014 to to make sure that he understood
what this was and didn't miss it because
the hype was starting to form already by
that by that time and I had already been
in several meetings the first first
blockchain company that I met at Morgan
Stanley was Ripple
they came in through a friend and he
pulled me in not knowing I knew anything
about about Bitcoin and I remember about
five minutes into the meeting putting my
pen down and saying oh my god this is
gonna tip and all the Morgan Stanley
people that we were arrayed across the
table from Chris Larson and and Patrick
Griffin the the whole ripple team at the
time there were probably five of them
and then five of us and Morgan Stanley
people looked at me like I was just from
Mars they like what the heck because
they didn't know anything about what was
what the ripple folks were saying and I
just remember Chris Larson the look on
his face he just he relaxed because he
knew he wasn't fighting an uphill battle
to educate everybody on the other side
of the table and it was just like it the
smile that came across his face when he
found a champion yeah and at that point
I that was the first time I realized
that you could apply this technology to
the mainstream financial sector and it
would it took a while for me to make
that connection because the I didn't
understand that that you could separate
in quote-unquote separate the blockchain
from Bitcoin of course you can't and we
can probably talk a little bit more
about that later I'm I'm one of many who
made a detour around enterprise
blockchain and have come back
Jimi song just gave a great interview a
few weeks back to lorrison about that
about his trip through through do you
think that's it
this is really important right so do you
think that it's almost a requirement in
order to start out get excited you find
out the technology and then you have to
explore all of the intellectually
possible scenarios and then you end up
coming back to what is in reality
probably the most likely application
well it's interesting that's what Jimmy
did and he's obviously a technologist so
we came at it from different
perspectives but both ended up in the
same place essentially concluding you
know the enterprise stuff is okay for
things probably outside of financial
services right supply chain is where
it's taking off do you really need a
blockchain for that probably not but the
truth is that it's a marketing gig and
it's causing some very interesting
things to happen in supply chain there's
a company in Wyoming called beef chain
that that that is doing exactly that to
track the provenance of Wyoming beef
it's solving a problem that nobody knew
how to solve and now this technology has
sort of opened up the conversation so I
don't mean to impugn enterprise
blockchain across the board but but I do
believe and I did say in a Forbes column
recently a lot of enterprise blockchain
was essentially made obsolete by the ice
announcement because what ice did was
break the seal in embracing digitally
native assets and that's what Jimmy said
to to Laura was ultimately why he
concluded that it was very difficult to
apply blockchain not Bitcoin so to speak
to the enterprise world because you have
a lot of things like trade breaks and
reversals that the regulators have to be
able to come in so effectively the
regulators have to be a super node and
therefore you really aren't
decentralized therefore you're better
off working in a centralized database
architecture to paraphrase Jimmy's I
hope I haven't missed miss stated I came
at it from a different perspective which
was I knew that Wall Street wasn't going
to accept Bitcoin so I was more from a
legal and compliance perspective
thinking all right how do we actually
figure out how to go through that
intermediate step of the walled garden
to use Andreas's phrase where you know
the intranet first before internet
that's the way enterprises think they
don't take big big leaps they do take
more incremental steps and nobody was
interested in
in wholesale replacing their their IT
architecture in which they've invested
billions so I knew this was gonna be a
slow process but I was pleasantly
surprised by the ice announcement that
they are embracing natively digital
assets that is a big deal because that
means they just leapfrogged over that
whole tokenization blockchain not
Bitcoin philosophy and ice can do a lot
that's very positive with that I hope
they do absolutely so one thing that we
spent a lot of time thinking about is
this idea that you know you can own four
types of assets right stocks bonds
currencies commodities and in this
digital world
there should be digital stocks bonds
currencies yeah bond it's right and so
Bitcoin being probably the most
attractive asset to date right in the
currency bucket yeah and over time as
these other assets or digital assets get
introduced
how does Wall Street interact with that
right because I think to your point
they're more evolutionary than
revolutionary yes how how do you you
know see this playing out and shouldn't
frankly the crypto community trust Wall
Street
well that latter question is as a whole
a whole can of worms but how I think
this is gonna play out is look we all
understand that digitally natively
digital assets can can trade and settle
instantly and or or in near real-time
the technologists would correct me but
but but but a lot faster than then the T
plus two days trade date plus two days
settlement that we have now on Wall
Street and it's going to cut out a lot
of the intermediaries that take cuts and
create counterparty risk where it
otherwise would not exist yep so I
actually think very much that the that
the ICO craze a lot of folks are
thinking that there's there's a lot of
scams and of course there are but
there's something really important from
a corporate finance perspective that
comes out of that which is that
investors are rationally in my opinion
willing to give up the traditional
covenants and preferences that they
usually you
- getting in investments in exchange for
not having to deal with this crazy
clearing trading clearing and settlement
infrastructure on Wall Street which
exposes them to all kinds of risks that
they just don't need to be exposed to so
they get instant settlement with no
counterparty risk if they are trading
these these utility tokens or security
tokens how much of that is driven by
human greed and just the idea that price
will appreciate and so a lot of it right
ok so talk to me about do you think that
investors are actually making a rational
trade-off in terms of hey I actually
don't like that you know settlement
system and so therefore I'm willing to
give up or do you think some of it is
human greed and by proxy that's what the
trade-off that they're making I think
it's I think it's the latter I'm not
sure that that a lot of folks are
necessarily going through that thought
process that we just talked about they
instinctively understand that they
outright own this asset it's not an IOU
from anyone and therefore I'd rather own
that it's it's real property it's it's
something that I can that I can maintain
on my own and and and if my Broker
Dealer goes bust I'm not stuck as a as
an unsecured creditor to a leveraged
institution like the customers of MF
Global or Lehman Brothers were right
where they end up taking a haircut right
so I think a lot of people do
intuitively understand that how are they
actually rationally making a mobility
and a lost severity to broker-dealer
default when they buy securities
probably not but I but again a you know
the wisdoms of Kratt wisdom of crowds
right there there it is intuitive and I
also do believe that this market has
shown that the crowdfunding rules and
the JOBS Act that Congress passed to
help make crowdfunding a lot easier they
failed and they failed because of the
bureaucracy involved in raising capital
so what this market I think is doing is
pushing
I hope the policy makers towards let's
actually have a JOBS Act to that that
actually tears down even more of those
bureaucratic barriers because it's
pretty clear that there is something
special here in
the structure of these icos and let's
actually help clarify the regulation so
far the SEC has not been friendly to
that but there are the folks on Congress
who are absolutely it's something we're
going back to the beginning of equity
investing etc right in terms of when
people first art investing in companies
there was no such thing as liquidity
preferences or shareholder rights etc
but you actually had the bearer
instrument yes yeah you actually owned
your your shares and so we've almost
come full circle to the extent just now
in the digital world right and so how do
you see that ripple impact across Wall
Street right if the retail investors are
willing to do this without going through
financial institutions yeah
does that force the financial
institutions to you know kind of move in
this direction as well or do you think
that they can hold out
oh I there they're gonna be forced to
move in this direction because they're
just gonna be disintermediated and
what's fascinating to me is that there
are there's a whole parallel
infrastructure of of Wall Street right
there are structures of these capital
raises we call them I SEOs but they can
be security token offerings whatever you
want to call it there there's a whole
capital market that's that's built up
around around these products so you've
got that you've got the advisers you've
got the exchanges you've got research
firms that that specialize in all of
this and and Wall Street is gonna get to
sooner mediated by them and the thing
that they cannot that Wall Street does
not offer right now and frankly isn't
set up very well to do it is to be able
to build tech you don't have people who
can design an ER c20 token and
understand how to market at an IC ora
Ora or an sto out to the investor
universe that's not something Wall
Street can do but I've had a number of
companies talk to me about corporate
coins corporate ERC 20 tokens and I
think it's very real it's as I've said
in one of the forbes.com pieces it this
is actually I think cheaper capital it's
it's securitization by another name and
so for a company to go out and raise
capital that way is very rational and
and I think that they're gonna find
cheaper capital either for startups and
we see
that right the the the amount of VC
investment in this industry compared to
the token investment in this industry
you know the tokens at surpassed VC
investment in blockchain 18 months ago
but now the whole token industry is 30
percent of what VC the traditional VC
across the board not just blockchain
right this is it's already happening
that's already disintermediating and and
it's 45 percent of the size of the IPOs
in in the first quarter oh sorry sorry
in the second quarter and 41 percent I
think was the number in the first
quarter so it wasn't just a flash in the
pan it's we've had six months of you
know that this this token market has
raised a very material amount of capital
institutional sized and that is
attracting companies to this market I
think we're gonna see you know more than
just the Kodak coin absolutely well it
in you know I think a lot about like
this power shift right so if you think
of when investing first started the
founders or owners of the business had a
lot of the power yep so they would go to
people and say hey give me money you
could have a claim on my cash flow over
time investors realize hey we have money
and so we have we've got some leverage
here and they continued to kind of
ratchet down on business owners or
founders and now what we're seeing is a
shift in power back to those founders
and entrepreneurs because what we're
doing is on a global basis you just open
it up and there's always an investor
who's willing to take less egregious
terms yeah but I also think that it is a
trade a trade off right the markets
actually been pretty good at weeding out
the scams so you know that's one of the
one of the benefits of crypto Twitter is
that you know people are ruthless and
and and so if it's just an outright scam
so but I think there's a different
relation because I think the detailer
measures out so there's a difference
between a scam yeah and let's say a
founder who says look when I raise
capital I'm looking for two things I see
for money and I'm looking for help yeah
right and so if I believe that there's
an investor who will give me money and
help but the terms are erroneous right
or kind of egregious yeah then I'm
willing to open that up to a wider set
of investors to find a better market
equilibrium for what this round pricing
should be absolutely and I think one of
the interesting things that come
out of that is that this is a big
competitive threat to the state of
Delaware and having worked when I while
I was at Symbian Symbian it was simians
idea to go start the Delaware blockchain
initiative Mark Smith got that done
before I got to Simeon and we were
gung-ho moving forward with the former
governor and then the incumbents came in
and then threw sand in the wheels under
the new governor and and and and here's
the irony based on what I just announced
that it's going to natively digital
assets it just takes away Delaware's
competitive advantage I don't see any
reason why a company in a start-up would
register in Delaware why because of
exactly what you just talked about they
now have a capital markets alternative
where they don't have they don't have to
go and be a Delaware corporation where
investors really are comfortable with
the state of Delaware because the law is
most defined there there's great case
law there's the Delaware Chancery Court
all those things fit the traditional
corporate equity issuance and preferred
share venture capital funding model but
now if you can actually issue tokens
you're just gonna have a very
different-looking pound sheet you're
just gonna have a big contingent
liability on your balance sheet but it
doesn't matter where you what you
organize as a company because you're not
raising capital by selling equity you're
raising capital through this
securitization type secured financing
type of vehicle which means that
Delaware law is not a competitive
advantage at all and I find that it's
just disappointing Delaware squandered
it's it's it's huge head start were two
and a half years after the announcement
of the Delaware blockchain initiative
and of course they were working on it
before it wasn't before Governor Mark
Hamill announced it at consensus in 2016
in that was I think April and and and
they are just maybe later this year I
think going to have a prototype to
consider at the state of Delaware so I
mean it's just it's it's pretty clear
what happened there yeah unfortunately
for them so sticking with state specific
legislation let's go to Wyoming great
you've done an incredible job there walk
us through there's five pieces of
legislation just walk us through kind of
what
happened in kind of where we are today
and why Wyoming has been able to kind of
get the stuff across the finish line
well it was just a fortuitous thing I
was just quietly because I happened to
get into Bitcoin pretty early had like a
lot of folks gains and was willing to
share the wealth and and also wanted to
solve a problem which is that there are
not a lot of female engineers and out
there not just in this industry but
across the board my dad had been
department head of Electrical
Engineering for at the University of
Wyoming so I thought well did this you
know endowing with Bitcoin gains of fund
for female engineers a lot of my boxes
right and I just quietly did it I wasn't
telling anyone about it and and just
assumed the University of Wyoming could
you know get an account with coinbase I
used to be on the Foundation board there
so I was you know helping them through
that and then ran smack-dab into the
Wyoming law problem which was that they
had one of the worst money transmission
laws and was one of three states
coinbase couldn't do business in and nor
could they pay or circle and it or any
of the other competitors and so I said
guys let's go fix that and it turned
into let's more than fix that let's
actually you know define utility tokens
as a new class of property digital
property that is exempt from securities
laws and from money transmission laws
and we exempted open blockchain tokens
from property taxes we did all kinds of
interesting things that that basically
made it a very crypto friendly state it
is the most crypto friendly state right
now absolutely and so what do you think
that does gonna incentivize people to
move to Wyoming their business right in
terms of to get a lot of this work done
there do you think they can have an
impact on other states or at the federal
level well great question at Wyoming is
the state that invented the limited
liability company in 1977 so it wasn't
actually that far-fetched that it was
going to be doing some interesting
things because it has a history like
Delaware of doing of being a leader in a
particular type of business entity
formation and so we wanted to but but
Delaware stepped in and and sort of
stole Wyoming's lead over the years as
being the place where most LLC's formed
and so this was a
chance for Wyoming to try to steal that
weed back and and and you know it's been
it's been good a lot of folks have have
formed companies in Wyoming haven't
looked at the recent numbers but I just
see it through the Wyoming go octane
coalition still every day a couple of
companies reach out looking for
attorneys in Wyoming looking for
references for people who can help them
structure their their token offering you
ask the question about the federal
impact I there definitely are some
congressmen who are who watched what
happened in Wyoming and who very much
like what happened in Wyoming but the
federal issue is a whole new can of
worms and it's fascinating because
securities law is has been adjudicated
by the Supreme Court to be a federal
jurisdiction but property is the
jurisdiction of the states so actually
in the next Wyoming legislative session
the task force that I'm on we're gonna
have a couple of new bills and one of
them is going to actually pull out the
utility token language from the
Securities title which is where it
resides right now in the in the chapter
if you will of Wyoming law that is
securities it's an exemption from
securities we're actually going to pull
it out and create it as a new class of
property that is for the legal minded
folks out there the Uniform Commercial
Code is state law commercial commerce is
state law and so if we can actually get
it into a classification of property as
opposed to securities it actually
increases the probability that if there
ever is litigation that a judge is going
to say that's not federal jurisdiction
so we're setting it up for folks to to
come in who want to stay in the United
States but recognize that there's
there's legal risk up certainly not
advising folks to do anything without
getting independent counsel I'm not
giving legal or investment advice here
but but we have had a number of
companies who have very publicly said
they want to stay in the United States
and they're coming to Wyoming because
they just don't believe that the federal
government should be running American
businesses offshore absolutely no I
completely agree what um what's
something that you believe in a crypto
space that you think a wide majority of
people would disagree with you on
oh the bitcoins gonna take over us money
that's the I really do believe it's
gonna take money okay explain to us
that's how you get there well I think
it's gonna take 20 years I may be wrong
because again what ice did that's one of
the benefits of what I said was embraced
natively digital assets and so I think
that change over from how we do it now
we're where we have this crazy system
where every financial asset with very
few exceptions is an IOU from a
leveraged financial institution that
might go bust most people don't realize
that yes the stocks in Europe brokerage
account are not stocks they're an IOU
from your broker so the bank account
deposits that you have it's not your
money it's an IOU from a bank and they
may not pay it back to you so I do think
that that you know I thought that it
would take a while to take to tear down
that infrastructure and I do think it
will take a while but the the the that's
why I said ice broke the seal that's
that's one of the things I complimented
them on they they left over the
blockchain not Bitcoin detour if you
will but I thought was going to take the
industry ten or twenty years and just
went straight to natively digital assets
so I you know we may be surprised at how
how fast this takes off the technology
needs to come up to speed pretty clearly
I'm excited about Lightning Network I
now that I understand what that is in
not certainly at a technologists depth
but more sort of from a from a
philosopher and business depth of
understanding that you know that really
could make a big difference yeah do you
think that the accelerate do you think
that the adoption of Bitcoin as money is
being accelerated by some of the
hyperinflation we're seeing around the
world oh no question yeah no question
we're on the day where we're recording
this is you know Turkey is we're having
an emerging market correction shall we
say in in a number of emerging markets
and and yeah the the bitcoins already
having a big impact in places like
Venezuela and historically it has been a
safe haven asset the Wall Street flows
did make it more positively correlated
to
traditional financial assets it was say
in the Cyprus situation very
non-correlated it was a safe-haven flow
and and one of the things that I've
literally just written in in in the book
chapter draft is that but bitcoin will
return to its roots as a safe-haven
asset it is very very interesting and if
that occurs and given what I just did do
you think Isis one of or the most
important company in crypto right now I
do and and it's a double-edged sword
I've been positive about them in the in
the conversation here that we've
recorded so far but as you know as we
were chatting earlier there there there
are definitely a lot of downsides to the
way that Wall Street is going to
approach Bitcoin what's the biggest fear
there well they're gonna rehypothecation
and they're going to create more claims
to bitcoin than actually exists and it's
so fascinating then you know then the 17
million bitcoins that exist it's so
fascinating to talk to both the why the
the Wall Street folks as well as the
crypto folks in folks understanding what
that really means I think a lot of my
Wall Street compatriots don't understand
that that's a big part rehypothecation
is a big part of how Wall Street makes
money it creates more paper claims than
there are actual assets so the dole food
cases is Exhibit A for that forty nine
point two million brokerage statements
saying that that the folks owned dole
food shares but there were really only
thirty-six point seven million shares
outstanding and all forty-nine point two
million brokerage statements were valid
that was a Delaware court case how did
the financial system create one-third
more claims to dole food shares than
there were real dole food shares it's
the it's the market for pledged
collateral it's it's all the securities
lending reification and and and the like
that that takes place on Wall Street
where the accounting systems lose track
of who really owns what and basically
turning those assets into io u--'s if if
you actually owned the real dole food
shares you would never have had anything
like that happen yep if you own the real
Bitcoin you will never have anything
like that happen but Wall Street that is
a big part of their business model they
like they want to inter mediate
trades and so if they can inflate the
number of underlying assets they
intimate inter mediate more trades and a
lot of folks have been shocked on the
crypto side to hear this is how Wall
Street works and interestingly there's
been some wall street people who stood
up in the in the crypto in the Twitter
debates and said and defended this and I
that is absolutely a rational position
they're defending it as this is what
brings liquidity to markets this is what
greases the skids of trading and this is
what's going to bring liquidity to
Bitcoin and a very respected person
actually said to me that this
I won't identify folks just just because
these are not personal debates their
substantive debates and I don't want to
personalize it but said to me that Wall
Street is is going to fix the
quote-unquote problem that that Bitcoin
has which is that it is limited to 21
million coins and that scarcity is its
quote unquote problem and that is that
is absolutely how Wall Street thinks
about it but the crypto folks obviously
knows like know that but they love the
scarcity exactly that's listening to and
reading the quotes from the CEO of vice
talking about needing to centralize
Bitcoin talking about needing to bring
trust and transparency to Bitcoin these
are just antithetical to Bitcoin and the
crypto folks are you know lumber a
number of people use the word word
cringe-worthy when hearing them talk
about this but the Wall Street folks
read that and say well exactly there's
such a misunderstanding between the two
but it is not just a communication
misunderstanding it is a deep
philosophical difference absolutely what
do you wish that people on Wall Street
understood about the crypto community
that maybe they don't like what is the
biggest disconnect that if that got
solved you think a lot of this would
would kind of be easier that that that
were all druggies and dark web users and
yeah there's still an enormous overhang
of that perception in in the community
and from Wall Street's perspective yeah
III say all the time I say the the
currency of choice of every drug dealer
terrorist you know money launderer in
the world US dollar
and the other piece too I think that you
know Wall Street hasn't yet figured out
is there's a gentleman in law force
community who said look from our
perspective we want every criminal to
commit crimes with their hands on a
keyboard yeah right absolutely so
bitcoin is a perfect example of what can
occur when there is the you know kind of
the trackability etc of a currency it's
more trackable than US dollars for sure
and I believe FinCEN's the new head of
FinCEN just came out and said that
speaking out a Bitcoin conference or
blockchain event in Chicago if I'm not
mistaken and said exactly that this is
actually more traceable than the US
dollar now that they understand how to
trace it it's amazing yeah okay so let's
ask for it let's Wall Street bangs a
head against the wall for a while right
and I just kind of broke the seal we've
10 15 20 years from now what do
quote-unquote retail products in crypto
look like once washer gets involved like
what do you think are the the kind of
most obvious things as an ETF is it
something else but what does that look
like well I do think it's an ETF and
again that's a double-edged sword there
are a lot of folks who are thinking that
that's going to be a savior of the price
correction that we've had in crypto and
I'm not so sure about that and and I
just saw Tour de Meester make reference
to the when the gold ETF was introduced
I think gold prices were up 350 percent
within that period and there's a big
difference between the between what Wall
Street was back then in 2004 and what
Wall Street is today there's so much
more securities lending and
reapplication of collateral than
happened back then and so the price
action was more pure and and now I'm not
so sure because of I was just talking
over the weekend up at a free state
picnic with some folks who work in the
Wall Street industry we were just
comparing notes and we were talking
about the securities lending market and
and how basically after the financial
crisis so many of the mutual funds
especially defined contribution plans
like 401 K is turned off securities
lending after the Northern Trust Fund
had a problem with securities lending
and the entire defined contribution
market went non lending a lot of the
defined benefit market went not let non
lending as well and everyone
the lending market thought well gosh
securities are we're gonna have a lot
more you know spreads are gonna widen
out we're gonna make more profit on what
we're trading and that we're gonna have
a lot more scarce assets that's sort of
hard to borrow or special assets that
are that are so meaty for Wall Street to
intermediate because the profit margins
are so wide and guess what actually the
number of scarce and hard to borrow
assets went down you took out the entire
defined contribution and defined
benefits markets out of securities
lending how did that happen the reason
is because the accounting systems are
manipulatable shall we say so I don't
think that looking back at the 2004 gold
example is is actually we're not gonna
see a replay of that because Wall Street
has figured out how to reallocate assets
and that whole securities finance market
has has now consolidated it used to be
very disparate but what was happening
was the hedge funds were are being the
investment banks funding desks
themselves so they'd go they'd go to the
prime brokerage desk and and put on one
side of the trade and then take the
other side of the trade with the repo
desk at the same investment bank and
collapsed and collect a spread because
the two part the two parts of the
investment bank weren't working with
each other and they were pricing things
differently and now what's happened is
that's all consolidated at all the
investment banks into one department and
so all those different places where
assets are lent and relent in any sort
of rehypothecation I'm using that form
that that term very broadly but that's
how that's how Wall Street makes its
money and there's so much more of that
than happened back 15 20 years ago
absolutely we talk a lot about the
decentralization of the currency
prevents it from being killed by
government yeah do you think that some
of Wall Street's tactics can kill
Bitcoin well I think they can they can
really Kate it I put out a piece
yesterday the R and C words reification
and commingling excuse me those are
those are dirty words but that is how
Wall Street makes its money and what's
fascinating this is kind of an inside
baseball you're a fan
this is kind of an inside baseball piece
and I would have thought that it
wouldn't have gotten much much play but
it was already not even not probably
about 20 hours after putting it up it's
already had more than 6,000 views so
millat of people are wanting to learn
they understand that there's something
here and and and I don't mean to be the
bearer of the news some folks have
wanted to shoot the messenger but I
stood up the moment that ice came out
and announced it and said this is not
good for the price of Bitcoin and the
and you know look at what's happened
since then has had about a 20 percent
correction a lot of folks said a lot of
folks expected that this would be a huge
positive right and and and I'm so
sympathetic and and and feel the same
myself empathetic probably a better word
of about wanting to have the mainstream
acceptance that we've all been craving
this is validation that we have
something really special here and we're
no longer these sort of you know kids
off in the corner playing with their you
know fancy tech toy or we're being taken
seriously and there's so much positive
to take away from that but it is a
double-edged sword and I do believe that
it has suppressed the price and the
reason is because now though the I mean
it's it's it's hard to say everything
that has suppressed the price but if you
look at it that day it's pretty clear
that that ice news actually there was a
lot of selling in Bitcoin that day and
that was the only news that particular
day it was a week ago Friday absolutely
what um if you're sitting there and
you're running a Wall Street Bank today
right your diamond or whoever right and
you see this asset class emerged start
to grow and you say I'm willing to
sacrifice my short-term profits for long
term sustainability with this as a you
know mainstream asset class what do you
do right what would you do as the head
of that Wall Street bank well I think
you do what Goldman does and I and I
I've multiple times written that Goldman
was the one that among the banks that
was different
when when I and my colleagues at Morgan
Stanley we're going to meet ups
clandestinely on you know after hours
and on weekend
and you know 2014 trying to keep our
heads down and not reveal to the world
that we who we worked for and not to
reveal our interest internally either
and our day job goldman folks were the
ones that didn't feel that there was an
acceptance a cultural acceptance within
Goldman of accepting curiosity and
accepting wanting to branch out and
think outside the box and the other
investment banks all seemed to ratchet
that down and I just was chatting with
somebody who's a who's working out at
another investment bank literally
yesterday and he said you know the
compliance Department is still these
things are so risky and it's dark web
and no one
you can't verify who you know the
counterparty on the other side and very
negative still so I think a lot of the
banks are still being you know run by
their compliance departments in that
regard but they're but that but they're
missing out so why am i singing out
Goldman Goldman is you know they're
they're putting together a crypto
trading desk Lloyd blank line was was at
the time the CEO one of the one of the
only CEOs one of the only Wall Street
Titans who actually came out and and
said positive things about Bitcoin and
said you know there was a time when
paper money was thought of looked at
askance as well and this was when Jamie
Dimon famously said he fire anyone and
then you know when he said that I
I understood that because that's exactly
how I felt if I put popped my head up at
Morgan Stanley at the time you know and
a lot of these banks have pushed out
their their crypto people and now
ironically they're scrambling to find
them absolutely it is an exciting 10
that we're living through what um what's
the one area people aren't talking about
that you think they should be well this
Wall Street stuff the Wall Street entry
this is a big deal and it's clear that
that it's going to take a lot of patient
education of folks to understand both on
the Wall Street side why it is such a
big deal but you got now the ten ton
gorilla of market infrastructure in the
US embracing negatively digital assets
and I think the fixed income market is
going to go in that direction pretty
fast because why would you
to issue in paper form anymore in global
security form it's just you know now
that ice is accepting natively digital
assets game-changer for Wall Street I
think a lot of folks don't understand
that and then on the crypto side it's
wait a minute Wall Street really isn't
your friend here there are yes they're
gonna bring liquidity yes they're gonna
bring institutional investors in but
they're also going to create Bitcoin
substitutes off the chain and it's not
as though you know the the custodial
exchanges someone just today said hey
mount GOx did that absolutely we didn't
own real bitcoins if we owned bitcoins
at Mount GOx we owned an IOU from out
GOx and a lot of folks didn't understand
that but I like to repeat what Charlie
Shrem has said you have to lose money in
Bitcoin before you before you make it
and I lost some coins in mal Cox because
that was the place when I was buying
that everybody bought and I didn't fully
understand that but boy that was that
was really cheap tuition it was money
well spent that loss to me was money
well spent because I learned that lesson
I didn't know in real Bitcoin and it
wasn't until I pulled my private keys
off and ie pulled my bitcoins off that I
understood that I finally owned real
Bitcoin absolutely it's so funny right
for somebody who learned about 2012 got
into 13 2014 right for us to be sitting
here you know just a few years later and
to be reminding people that wall Charice
not your friend
yeah right that probably wasn't
something you had to be saying in 2013
but the people around the table but it's
so fascinating the knee-jerk reaction
was oh my god this is so positive and
yes in some ways but it's not
universally positive and and and I just
want to be very patient and respectful
because a lot of really smart people
just haven't gone down that other
besides rabbit hole yet and it's smart
people on both sides it's it's the Wall
Street people saying what I sees getting
into Bitcoin and it's the crypto people
saying what we can have off chain
fractionally reserved Bitcoin
substitutes so it's it's boy it's time
for a lot of folks to to go down the
other side's rabbit hole and really
learn well what a nice tick - it's a
technologists view right is it's math
right and so you can look at the numbers
that you've got there
when they get exposed to what is
essentially financial engineering yeah
right it's something that they've just
never thought of absolutely and so it's
this you tell you know you mean to tell
me that people are actually gonna buy a
thing that represents Bitcoin but
they're not gonna buy a Bitcoin well and
interestingly when we start explaining
that in we skew now but the Twitter's
gone absolutely nuts people are talking
to each other a lot of folks really
understand this and explain it to help
explain it to to peers it's people kind
of again realizing oh my god you mean
that's what Kraken and bit mechs are and
okx are doing yeah they've been doing it
all along they've been there basically
web 2.0 companies that create a
centralized layer application layer and
they record transactions to the
underlying chain but they're commingling
the bitcoins in an omnibus account any
time you have it you use a custodial
exchange or a custodian or you know you
store your coins at at coin base or
circle or bitpay guess what you're doing
you know you have an IOU from them and
less here in coinbase vault and it's the
same thing and so a lot of folks didn't
really real realize that I know Andreas
has been trying to help people
understand that you don't own your
private keys unless you don't own your
Bitcoin unless you have your private
keys he he can't repeat that often
enough is what I found because even
within the hardcore crypto community
there were a lot of folks who didn't
understand that nuance and so again it's
just patient respectful education and
this I snooze definitely has caused a
lot of folks to open up and and learn
absolutely we end each podcast I let you
ask me one question though my least
favorite part of this cuz I never know
if you will ask but anything that you'd
like to ask where do you think what do
you think the ice implications of Wall
Street are cuz I know you've submitted a
letter to the SEC uh regarding the ETF
do you agree yeah I approach so I I do
agree right I think that there's two
separate pieces here right one is I
truly believe that
there's a lot of people who are
interested they're intrigued yeah
and they don't have the technical
competence or the intellectual curiosity
to go figure out or the time yeah how do
I figure out what is Bitcoin what are
the risks associated what is the
potential benefit and how do i purchase
hold securely etc all they know is this
Bitcoin thing is interesting people are
talking about it they keep getting
stolen I'm just gonna go about my day
yeah when you get an ETF for these
retail products etc right there's uh
there's a line to thread there between
you're giving access to a class of
investors or you know a subset of
investors that probably probably would
never go to coinbase right and go try to
buy it because they want to buy it
through their financial advisor yeah
they just want they they want somebody
to yell out when something goes wrong
right and so I think that you know for
those people this is good because it
will give them some exposure even though
it's not the best exposure at the same
time the financial engineering that
comes in is quite scary right and so I
think that one thing that I don't have
an answer to but I keep thinking through
is what is the trade-off right how that
the positive effect of the news right
for this base of retail investors who
frankly it's a pretty big aggregate
number of investors that have a lot of
money yes and so there will be an inflow
of capital once these things actually
you know come online and our and our
operational but is does that actually
outweigh the you know you the 10,000
pound gorilla of Wall Street now having
the ability to go do their do what they
do okay and you know there's an element
of is this almost a Trojan horse right
you know you get in the into the fort to
attack by saying hey we're gonna give
access to these retail investors
everyone's cheering in to your point
they don't see you know kind of what's
happening in the background
I don't know right and so frankly I
probably haven't been around long enough
in a kind of traditional financial world
to really understand how to measure that
that you know kind of pro and con impact
but I think it's one of the most
fascinating things because you you move
from you know Bitcoin four or five years
ago was in you know billions tens of
billions of you know market cap or
circulation yes now we're moving into
institutions that that's on their
balance sheet
right and now all of a sudden you're
playing with you know an institution
that three years ago or four years ago
could have just bought the entire supply
of Bitcoin so you know you're one of my
partner's always talks about going
straight from high school to the pros
like Bitcoin just went straight from
high school to the pros
yeah and are we ready right I don't know
yet and I think that's gonna be one of
the most fascinating things to watch
yeah great great points great minds
thank you so much for joining us we
really really appreciate it I know that
that this is on short notice so you're
you're fighting the good fight and I
think that a lot of people are listening
so thank you it's my honor and pleasure
to great to finally meet you I can't
believe we've never actually crossed
paths person personally previously and
and yeah let's just help educate keep up
the good work
absolutely thanks so much they